Well, the show is called "Around the World in 80 Plates."
We're going around the world in 80 plates.
12 chefs are about to embark on a culinary adventure of over 60,000 miles.
They're cooking in a foreign place, a foreign cuisine, serving it to the locals.
The locals decide who did a better job of the overall experience,...
...interpreting the local cuisine, the service, the food, of course.
So Cat and I deliver that news, a little bit of fun.
And then Cat and I also decide who we thought was the most valuable chef.
So we give that person an award, which is immunity in the next city that they move directly on to.
Hello, chefs!
Welcome to London!
And welcome to "Around the World in 80 Plates."
We don't want Bravo to know how good a job this was, okay?
We're going to ask for more money for Season Two.
Exactly.
It was tough, rigorous.
We had to travel a lot.
And we're away from our families for long periods of time.
Horrible.
Horrible conditions!
Very tough.
Very tough for us.
Very hard job.
Very hard.
We got to travel the world.
Of course, we saw the most amazing sites and got to see this incredible competition...
...unfold right under our noses and be a part of it.
We literally watched it, tasted and smelled it.
It was a dream job.
Dream job.
Okay, you got me.